the jurgen experience so they hired the
guy the best friends of the lab to
investigate the lab
right it's like hiring robert kardashian
to investigate oj
you know what i mean it's like and and
when they interview these guys on tv
they always say same thing don't you
want the best friends of the lab to
interview the lab isn't that
we know the most about it we're doing
the research it would be like robert
kardashian being like
i know oj really well you know let me do
the investigation i'll figure out the
truth i'll get to the bottom of this
right so anyway so they go to the lab
for three hours talk to their best
friends looking for straight line did
you do it no we didn't do it okay
case closed and then they concluded in
their who report that
the lab theory was very unlikely we
don't need to look into the lab case
closed
and everybody was like oh that doesn't
make any sense we can't have that
these guys have a conflict of interest
their careers are tied to this lab
if the lab were found to be guilty again
we don't know i don't know you don't
know
peter desert doesn't well maybe he knows
but i don't think he knows
you know their legacy this entire
project of 200 billion dollars
200 million dollars rather to dig up
viruses all over the world
would be kaput it would have to
necessarily be stopped this whole
industry
okay now here's the part where i'm going
to get a little controversial are you
ready
is it okay sure okay so
if i've gotten you that far again just
to say that
i don't blame anyone out there for
having this notion that like this lab
accident theory is kind of a kooky thing
that like
was cooked up by mike pompeo or
something like that i get why you think
that
but now trump's not he's not here
anymore right we don't have to argue
about trump anymore hopefully
ever again right and we can just look at
the
piles of circumstantial evidence and
there's a plenty of circumstantial
evidence
that it could have come there's some
circumstantial evidence that could come
from nature
i feel that the lab theory has more
compelling circumstantial evidence
because again
they were doing that kind of research
they also there was a huge cover-up and
the
virus database went mysteriously offline
somehow in december 2019
it's also the evolution of the virus
itself right that's what robert so
robert redfield
who was the cdc director of the time a
trained virologist he says i took a look
at this
virus and i concluded that his so
powerful that
it must have been evolved in a lab
setting and he pointed to the game of
functional research and they called him
a racist that conspiracy theorists
and all the rest yeah all right now
here's the controversial part
that the godfather of that industry
the head of the the of the pyramid is a
guy
you may have heard of called anthony
falchi i've heard of that guy right
yeah do you want to hear more yeah okay
so anthony falchi the hero of the
pandemic
is the most important person in the
world of gain of function research there
is
in other words he is not just him
there's francis collins at the nih and
some other people but
basically he he is the one dispersing
all the grants for this
he is the one who pushed to turn it back
on after obama turned it back off that's
a whole nother crazy story
he turned it back on without really
consulting the white house that's
breaking news
never been reported just broke some news
on your show right now
yes uh he consulted the office of
science and technology policy which is
like a part of the white house but he
didn't
uh you know the white house put a pause
on it and then he like undid the pause
it the details are a little sketchy i'm
not saying that he did anything
necessarily wrong or illegal i'm just
saying that a lot of people that i know
inside the trump administration had no
idea this had turned back turned back on
he found a way to turn it back on
in the mess of the trump administration
because the trump administration was
full of a bunch of clowns
right so at the end you could get stuff
done if you just knew how to work the
system without you
is the head of that system why what was
his incentive that's his
that's everything that's his whole
career that's so what he would say and
uh to be fair again to be perfectly fair
to him
he's trying to predict the next pandemic
he thinks this is the way that you
predict the next pandemic
by digging up all these viruses we got
to dig up more and more viruses
and play around with them because we're
going to find how they evolve then we're
going to come up with therapeutics and
vaccines and all this stuff but there
were no therapeutics
right but we did have vaccines quicker
than most because
the darpa funded a program to make our
mrna vaccines
10 years ago that actually worked you
know that was a military-funded program
but we can get to that in a second but
that's
not related to this right so
my that's that's a very fair observation
in other words
the the 200 million dollar program to
predict and preempt the pandemic
failed to predict and preempt the
pandemic but it may have also sparked
the pandemic
may have sparked but here's my my
question when i
read all about the research they were
doing i didn't see
what they were doing to prevent it i
just saw they were what they were doing
was examining these viruses and trying
to find out how they work and trying to
see what happens when they get more
virulent but what i didn't see
is that the invention of therapeutics or
that i hear what you're saying i'm
i'm willing to give these scientists the
benefit of the doubt that their honest
goal was to
create do good science to prevent and
predict oh i am too
that's not what i'm saying i don't know
if they produce therapeutics
what i'm saying but did they have a lack
of funding in that department was all
the fun i don't know
allocated towards examining the viruses
themselves and not
towards developing some sort of uh a
therapeutic
uh i i don't it's a good question i
don't know they answer that question
okay but what i do know is that
the majority of their time was spent
digging up viruses in the wild and
bringing them back to these labs but
fouchy when he started it back up
did he start it back up with the intent
to just uncover more information so
be better informed his argument was this
is vital research
the longer we pause it the more danger
that we're in
i'm trying to save the world and so we
got to turn this stuff back on because
this is how we're going to save the
world from the next pandemic which i'm
sure he believed
i'm sure a lot of these people believed
but there is another school of thought
out there
and the other school of thought is hey
instead of taking 200 million dollars to
dig up viruses and make them more
dangerous why don't you put that money
into monitoring surveillance in the
places where the bats are
in other words if you put resources
where the outbreaks are likely to occur
then you can squelch them when they pop
up because actually viruses change every
day
and trying to predict the pandemic is a
fool's errand that's another
scientific school for that's not the one
that falci's in right but the reason
that there's no debate about this is
because the nih and niaid structure are
such that
everyone gets funded by them they're
funding everybody so if you are in the
field of virology
there's a 99.99 that you're getting
money from anthony fauci in one way or
another
your grants your careers your
chairmanships so there's no
there's no dissent allowed in that
community i learned a lot about the
scientific
community and the virology
so no debate i talked i've talked to
scientists all the time who say i i
think this gain of function research is
really dangerous i can't say anything
i'm going to lose my grant
you're going to lose my career this
happens to me all the time and when
robert robert redfield
spoke up because he's a big mocker and
he's ahead of the
head of cdc he said it it's my opinion
that it came from the web
because he can't declassify a bunch of
classified information on cnn
right but he's talking about what he
knows right it's obvious to everyone
who's in the know that he's seen the
intelligence and he's not just
talking out of his ass he's not some joe
schmo virologist he was the head of the
cdc he's seen all of the secret secrets
even the stuff i never
got got a whiff of and he and he went on
tv and said
hey uh i think this probably came from
the lab we should probably look at the
lab
and he was called a racist and a
conspiracy thing but by far
what he's saying but fauci's disagreed
with him publicly right so that's the
thing so if you if you just think about
it just for once again
i i'm begging people out there just like
think again whatever you thought about
the lab accident it doesn't matter
whatever you tweeted in
2020 march it doesn't nobody cares right
and the same thing let it go yeah
because it's all confirmation bias now
like oh i
i said i tweeted this in march 2020 and
i want it to hold up nobody cares what
you tweeted in march 2020.
let's just have a rational moratorium a
conversation about what are the likely
ways we got into this horrible crisis
that we're in and so for people in the
know who are listening to
robert redfield it's clear that he's
calling out anthony fauci in other words
he's pointing to the gain of function
research which he knows because he's the
head of the cdc
reports up to fouchy he knows that right
but he's not saying that because
even that's too hot for him to say it's
hot and too and the scientists are not
going to say that either
now you have a lot of people sort of on
the on the right wing media
and the maga media who've been saying
that for a long time but they don't have
any credibility with the mainstream
media and i'm just like in that weird
space
where like i've wrote a book about you
know u.s china relationship so i had all
these
this good reporting and i'm not bag of
media because i criticized trump in my
columns all the time
so i am mainstream media but i'm saying
we should look at the lab and
it messes with people's minds because
they're like oh why is he doing this why
is josh approaching the lab i'm not
pushing the lab
that's the problem today with these
rigid ideologies
everyone's on teams it's all factional
yes but i don't care i don't even care
if the lab accident theory is true if
the natural origin theory is true then
great
i will leave the ticker tape parade
celebrating peter dazyk and anthony
falci
through down you know fifth avenue i'm
happy to do that
all i'm saying is that we have to also
look into this lab
these labs rather and that we can't hire
the best friends of the lab to look into
the labs because they have a clear
conflict of interest and they [ __ ] it
up already
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience